scritto film avatar la pasta ed eddie
long l'ex quindi il padre sì questo è il
figlio
che ho paura
per rendere cosi
dario ultima parte o biblica imac i
maghi che temete
oggi finiremo po più playtime due non
vedo una città insuccesso stesso presto
iniziamo subito voi mettetevi comodi
pratico con il natale un bel mi piace il
quale lotto perché se questo video
raggiunge i 10 mila mi piace faremo più
playtime 2 nella vita reale
spalleggiare 48 e ora vediamo cosa ci
aspetta se non avete visto gli altri
episodi andate primo a vedere gli altri
episodi cadavere poi tornati qui
arrabbiate questo video perché
altrimenti non capirete che sta
succedendo
l'altro molto infatti eravamo rimasti
bloccati qui e ti abbiamo visto kissi
misti come ultimo personaggio e prima
ancora abbiamo visto tantissimi anni web
di tutti colorati e stato molto
difficile ma ce l'abbiamo fatta non mi
ricordo da dove eravamo passati però a
chi si messi di nuovo sì o forse anche i
wacky questo
dopo la crisi mistiche deve essere ma
che carini perché mai tanto carina anche
ha sempre paura perché vede quella lì la
leva guarda noi per farci capire che
premierà la leva che si vede questa
volta di segue
e questa volta vetro dove stai andando
ma si sta proiettando brigate
seguì ricchissimi studiamo con fatti e
stilisti dove 6 attento e chi si
ok allora si
deve per l'elettricità vero sembra non
mi ricordo nella messa sì qui va lì
si sono sposati lo style uno skyphos
thunder possa spostare il carrello è la
meno forte ma forse è meglio che a
quelle acquisti per la città e poi dopo
hanno aspettato
forse si può aprire di qua
vediamo come
si riprenderà l'elettricità dall'altro è
un labirinto altro che i labirinti di
rob lowe infatti molto complicato stile
è molto più paurosa ma anche noi siamo
usciti adesso siamo un po persi porta
solo a causa di fatturato una cassetta
finalmente scopriamo altri segreti di
pochi slay time di quello che è successo
nella fabbrica
che cosa scopriremo questa volta c'è
qualcuno che questo è il creatore
e un po nervoso
ok allora abbiamo appena visto il video
di un impiegato che lavorava alla
fabbrica questa fabbrica questa di poppi
playtime e in pratica ha detto io sono
tornato indietro cioè ho finito il mio
turno di lavoro però sono tornato
indietro perché avevo dimenticato il
portafoglio e ho visto una mano
gigantesca è una creatura gigante con
tantissime zampe quindi credo che se
rivista ma milan blacks e l'addetto al
suo capo il capo ha detto ma che dice
non ne facciamo i giocattoli ho detto mi
conosci non ha voluto saperne niente
quindi forse il capo c'entra qualcosa se
lui ha deciso di iniziare gli
esperimenti su questi giocatori e
trasformarli in mostri
ok proviamo a prendere l'elettricità
d'acqua e poi meno male questo grappa
che celebrano anche gli infinite che
succede ora hai provato aprire questo
molla mai si vede però c'è apriste
e adesso e ora non lo so potete può
attivare questo potrà attivare uno dei
due non lo so questo vice
no non ha funzionato che proviamo a
dovesse ammettere quando l'elettricità
no quello di prima forza
no
bloccati
abbiamo posto c'è voluto un sacco di
tempo cosa dobbiamo fare meglio seguire
questo sto meglio sapere torino non
ricordo a dire spingilo mai carrellino
termoli dove stanotte le montagne rotta
ha distrutto qualcosa per i monti fuori
ma milo blackstone o no forse è meglio è
meglio non andare io credo che se
fossimo andati li saremmo caduti nel
baratro da un bambino black o dai c'è un
buco
dobbiamo dare credo
pero
credo di sì
ok siamo ritornati nella fabbrica chi si
messi ma chi vuol chi rosso sono già
paura di zona di wadi verde
aguila di arancione
quindi siamo riusciti a scappare
credo di sì ma cosa prova adesso quale
sarà la terza e ultima prova di mobil
home blacks potevo scappare con il
successo e forse sufficiente a salvare
anche poppi ecco questa è l'ultima da
stimolo
si
dice o se stesso bravissimo
il gioco finale
[Musica]
cerchiamo un gioco allora nostra
l'ultimo
tabù e
questo ci aspetterà i ragazzi attenta a
me sembrano teneva
cosa funzionava sì
lo so forse perché devo dire che dentro
sé qualcosa di molto perché costa meno
deve scappare qualche creatura nuova o
forse di quelle che conosciamo già
vediamo allora blu in un po inquietante
c'è un bruco con un po ci sarà un nuovo
personaggio
bruco un bruco
minacciato un sacco di nuovi personale
perché potrei bozzo a di web di tutti i
colori
e ora c'è quest'altro estremo molto
vediamo come si chiama ambrì to learn
affamato di imparare cioè mameli
conoscerne la rai come qui guarda sempre
che per troviamo
vuoi giocare con peter fill
c'è parla tipo come un cane però è un
bruco miliardi questo è un angelo mi
piace tanto
aspetta viper e quando hai assassino
cosa succede che cosa sta succedendo
cose è attivato lì c'è una leva
ok adesso qui
prendi meglio la mia
13 in aver basta a portare giù forza nei
crediamo attivato festa e poi doveva 3
trova il 2
forse qua
no non ci arrivo ok ragazzi forse
contiamo e ho capito devo salire la
sopra
noi vitale ce l'ha fatta ma voi non
avete idea di quanto era complesso
quello no ma non c'è in questo gioco si
sono impegnati per fare le cose più
è stato veramente difficile e adesso
finalmente possiamo proseguire forse
abbiamo attivato questa casa c'è una
porta qui ma quaeda dove siamo arrivati
forse si è aperta questa porta qui che
era chiusa vediamo sì stiamo entrando al
terzo gioco la terza prova
la carta presenta però i
giusti
benvenuto a stato di 6 band of course il
tour
sarà tutto buio
quando si sa se non elusive di cui
muovere
nuovo booking
praticamente ti puoi muovere solo quando
le luci sono spente quando gli amici
sono accese puoi solo guardarti intorno
ma non volevo perdere e in più c'è il
personaggio pj o come si chiama che ci
segue e se ti raggiunge aimerito dove
mamme
eccola mammi lunghezza per ha detto mi
hanno lasciato guarda al sola
il cui governo
guardate intorno mi hanno lasciato
paterson ha detto così come tu hai
lavorato qua si meriti di fare di fare
la mia stessa fine ho qualche mi hanno
lasciato qua da sala e ha fatto una
brutta fine bambino inglese
intoccabili lavoravamo qua quindi
abbiamo finalmente scoperto non
ti devi sbrigarti spiegato perché dicono
come la brava
io sono state il vicino vicino cagnolino
carino non aiuta il velino greco
sanitari
fermati fermati
scritto si spaventava
devi stare fermo queste cene luce accesa
ok ora prova vitale
non farti provare
a quanto previsto da battiato possiamo
camminare solo grande buio quindi adesso
quel caso io mi giro e una bugia
[Musica]
fa venire un ansia assurda tutto più con
bar e non dico tutto è tornato indietro
mi piace tornando indietro
no non mi dovevo cuore quanto sono la
luce come sempre le prove fanno venire
caruscino di questa volta proprio ad
andare
non ti muovere non mi piace per portarmi
fortuna
fermati
non sento che girino
mai stato
fermati dove devo andare penso tutto
dritto lì e non lo so se è una cosa
strana
tipo un due tre stella ma 10.000 volte
più complicato forse tutto dritto lì
sapendo che ci insegue
fa forse di vendere gli ho detto vai
bene ma
che paura che paura
nei
cieli ok dopo andare in quel tubo in cui
si è scritto visi
sono arrivato arrivato
i fermati ci sei quasi 6 vicinissima
[Musica]
adesso non si vede niente
ma quella uscita sei sicura non aspetta
una grande tronista no non mi dire
te destro è tornato indietro ok
riproviamo ragazzi alla fine di questo
video che i vadesi qual è stato secondo
appello proprio più difficile
secondo me questa e non lo stavamo
ancora finirla
sicuramente fa venire veramente
piano piace molto
[Musica]
la vita dove puoi farcela
tutto dritto dritto dritto
ma presa
paura
dietro questa volta chelsea in vantaggio
con rigori
sai che sta farla aggiungerti
si siano fermati
in girarti indiretti un popolo di me per
noi
noti sia distratta adesso dove stai
andando
tesoro segnato dalla parte sbagliata
vai
non so dove sto amando non ho idea di
dove sta andando ok qui c'è una luce
voglio andare di qua
l'idea inizio una cronista
non ti girate perché girare lui e dietro
sorpreso così come mi sono spaventato
anch'io mettiamo di nuovo
stiamo per tornare nel tunnel air
l'ansia è altissima è veramente
altissima la brace riguarda vinci
difficile questa prova
bisognerà vedere se questa attrazione ok
fermi fermi non ti girare insieme
all'apertura casinò che mi sta seguendo
ed epoche
ma ok tra gli uomini
inoltre
sono ok ma no però dall'altra parte
allora ok di qua
brava
come fa a vederci anche nei tubi
[Musica]
boh
forse qua non c'è niente ma è lui è lui
che si sta muovendo verso di te
a me sembra no ok
ma tu sei nato forse spaventato i contro
sono rovato devi andare dritto deve
saltare in quei cosi ok
[Musica]
per
un bomber eventi non potete capire
quanta anzi abbiamo
ci sto provando spero di non incastrarmi
qui
fermi
io non mi giro io non mi giro no non ti
io scappo basta
[Musica]
unitamente mette dentro
fermo il vissuto che dobbiamo dare
credo dritto
fermo non vedono in uscita
l'aiuto non so dove sto andando
e proiettili
non so dove andare non sapeva dare non
solo vedere
non ci sta vedendo vero queste qua siamo
nascosti non riesce a prenderci forse si
stanca andar via e andrà mio
lunghissimo forse sta andando via guarda
sta andando via non ci credo siamo
riusciti a farlo andare d aria
[Musica]
non sodo london and sono quella parte
quindi noi piace dobbiamo forse possiamo
andare lì
no sta ritornando
guardate è lì che si sta avvicinando ma
non dovrebbe prendersi qua vero
che faccia inquieta mettiamola così bene
almeno credo di sì perché si sta
allontanando insomma che si allontani
poi proviamo ad aggrapparci in sisport e
la dobbiamo stare attenti però muoversi
sempre con il buio si aspetta che
[Musica]
soprattutto sono due
ragazzi abbiamo provato 50 volte questa
parte finalmente siamo riusciti a
entrare qua dentro avessero tenuto a
rendere
ma io vado
attento non ti muovere con la luce ma
non c'è proprio niente
succede
ci bambino blacks ma milan blacks
dovete solo che tutto non siamo qui per
fortuna meno male non dovevo fare tutto
di volte è stato difficilissimo forse la
prova più difficile di tutte ora abbiamo
appendere qui forse sentiva la voce di
mobilio blacks ma non sappiamo
tutti pazzi forse bisogna scappare
come lo zio disobbedir mi dice ma quali
sarebbero le sue regole non ho capito
proviamo con la ricorda bio
psico professionalità e ora non lo so
dobbiamo andare
a qui ho bisogno di rendersi quasi
brava siamo in un'altra area della
fabbrica un altro giocato due trovate
queste babylon blacks questo ed eddie
long l'ex quindi il padre si è questo il
figlio era il figlio beau ibabylon
blacks farlo adesso per carini com'è
possibile che milo blacks abbastanza da
essere un giocattolo così felice casson
riusciva ad essere così forse hanno
fatto sparire il padre e il figlio
sapremo tutto speriamo di scoprirlo
riscopriremo qualche altro segreto sulla
vita di mont milon blacks ma ora
dobbiamo circa appare il più veloce
possibile prendere il treno ora che
abbiamo superato dove sono finite devo
prendere il treno scappare poi tutto
buio però si vede niente ok però è ora
nostri
obiettivi tigre che ora cosa si aspetta
qui c'è un vento non mi dire che c'è un
bambino rumore fortissimo b oppure
quell'altro cagnolino che ci ha fatto
venire un sacco di infarti mammamia
quello era difficilissimo
c'è qualcosa di che cos'è a un pupazzo
nostro che andiamo martito buio come
sempre non si vede niente ovviamente la
porta è chiusa
at the rose byrne ok e adesso dove
stiamo un'altra area della fabbrica
proviamo a salire queste scale ma ora
dovremo tornare a dover reggere il
trenino per riuscire finalmente a
scappare dalla fabbrica però cos'è
questo
ci sono due bottoni quale dovrò prendere
dice ruota di 90 gradi sopra lo zero
ah ok un ponte che dobbiamo passare da
quel ponte quindi forse la strada ed
allora in questo pugliese scritto
esperimento 12 22 mag milan blacks ma
meno blacks ha un'abilità unica di
allungare le braccia e piedi questo
include anche le sue dita
collo
insomma tutto è molto stile verso lo
staff e anche molto materna e si
comporta in modo voto
caloroso verso gli altri esperimenti
quindi è come se lei credesse di essere
l'amore tutti gli altri giocattoli e
molto protettiva il problema è che
l'ostilità sta diventando problematica
ma forse c'è una soluzione per metterla
al suo posto di era una richiesta di
trasferimento in una parte di massima
sicurezza per mo milan blacks ovviamente
perché abbiamo già visto quanto è
pericoloso poi se riusciremo a salvare
poppi poverina per si ok
dove dobbiamo andare però il buoni
voluto lui c'è beni 2 nessuno se ne va
via senza un gioco ok non hanno grate
gamestation bikers vediamo che cosa c'è
qui
preme il bottone
[Musica]
il giochino quello di dire gatto ok
quasi la fabbrica stanno ancora un david
sta funzionando la fabbrica sta facendo
tanti gol giovedì vi ricordate bonzo
nella prima prova testa di di azzeccarci
però che ci sono due leve una serve per
scienze nell'altra per salire e forse sì
forse ti diciamo salire allora
italiano tira
guardate che carini sembrano così carini
innocenti questi bonzo e poi c'è pure mi
ha cambiato la traiettoria
so che devono aver fatto qualche
disastro
tira un po più forte tiri premuto
c'è un motore nitro perché quello ok
girati
che se sei qualcos'altro c'è un motore
blu che programma
che non ti arrabbi moby non l'ex e
adesso stiamo dirottando tutta la
fabbrica
devo salire peso forma si proprio posso
dire un corpo più sopra aiuti almeno la
facciamo arrabbiare per bene ma fino a
farsi un altro bottone
e ne sono e per un altro
aspetto stiamo muovendo sì stiamo
facendo cadere tutti i papà olio c'è
praticamente stiamo rovinando la
fabbrica ma in realtà è meglio così
perché almeno insomma almeno non
usciranno più giochi malefici da qua
gioca ora
wow ok e li ho cambiato di nuovo la
direzione del avevamo pregresso forse
ora arrivano qua i giocattoli vediamo no
prova a premere quell'altro perché così
arrivino qui
ok viviamo spetta a non premere il
bottone rosso
no qua girano qua forse devo riprendere
questo no ma spetta forse ho capito devo
aspettare che si avvicini un giocattolo
quadri e poi
giocattolo
robbie preso giocattolo di banco e ora
torniamo così
abbiamo giocato lo possiamo
tiraggi nativa importi ancora qualcosa
mi dice che non è finita ancora coleen
perché ma milan l'ex un po silenziosa
minimamente che siamo riusciti a
spostare il ponte
dobbiamo mettere tra il giocatore
nell'altro po più playtime ok l'asta
scannerizzando ei
rientrare c'è qualcosa che non quadra e
vedi se c'è qualche qualcosa ad attivare
su ei che dato il giocattolo mi devi far
entrare
c'è qualcosa qui
una cassetta ma doveva che siamo altri
segreti di bo bibli time troverete
infatti non si è ok ragazzi abbiamo
trovato la cassetta mettiamo la stessa e
vediamo cosa dicono i prossimi segreti
della fabbrica scoprì vediamo
[Musica]
hanno ricevuto molte lamentele
riguardano milioni ok ha detto
praticamente che era di nuovo il capo
della fabbrica e ha detto che erano
ricerche ha ricevuto un sacco di
lamentele perché dicono che hanno visto
un ragno gigantesco camminare la
fabbrica noi sappiamo adesso che in
realtà la mammina un legale sui ha detto
vi volevo avvisare che non esistono i
ragni così giganti quindi smettetela di
lamentarvi anche lotti a lavorare non
era molto bravo questo capo importante
per questo che i giocatori si sono
rivelati ribellati ok ragazzi finalmente
siamo riusciti a risolvere dei puzzle
difficilissimi con l'elettricità questo
gioco su perché veramente difficile e
ora non lo so forse ora riusciamo a
tappare
dove siamo finiti era una trappola
chi ha paura va benissimo anche brutto
dice ora giocheremo per l'ultimo volo un
ottimo gioco è ancora più arrabbiata di
prima e anche tutta fork ho chiesto fino
quegli occhietti no anzi scherzavo e un
po malefica lascia il dottore dobbiamo
correre dobbiamo strappa abbiamo
dobbiamo scappare da lei tanto sta
contando se 67 di sì 98 76 o no dovevamo
non so dove sto andando non si è capito
rieti aiuto scappa scappa scappa
via e ora sembra che tenendo bene perché
ancora non ci ha mangiato vivo che ha
detto che vuole fare paura ho paura che
quasi abu chiusi e saremo quasi proviamo
prima salire perché finora non sento le
zampette t mobile che si no sono troppo
lo che questa non so dove sta andando di
qua meglio che non ti giri non ho
cosa c'è questo
ma dove stiamo finendo un po che abbiamo
allora qui c'è un gatto optional e va
siete pronti per il job seeker
o no
io me lo ricordo questo incubo
ok una statuetta ma milan blacks d'oro
che torniamo qui è
una strada sbagliata siamo tornati come
eravamo prima non lo so cos'è questo
una sera stessa uscita ma sembra che non
non funzionano sarebbe centro nato per
essere vero
ho aperto una porta non so come faccia
riesce a scappare
dobbiamo dare tutto
già preso però devo dire che gli occhi
tondi così sono cari via si abbiano
fatto sicurissima che per lei e paura si
stima per gli occhietti tondi sono
teneri dai
poi alla fine del video si scrive temi
scriveteci nei commenti qual è stata la
nostra prova lo scatto pronta è il
vostro personaggio preferito ovviamente
si mischia con tutto ciò che mi piace
ciao mamma non me ne rimango qui
in passato si
è rimasto fatte se per farlo può fare si
è cercato qualche altra parte io rimango
qui un pochettino la
mettiamo ok siamo tornati su e adesso
perché vorrei passiamo da quei giusto
liberiamoci però se ne è andata adesso e
vini molto per me c'è qualcosa da
rimpiazzare perché è stato danneggiato
che cosa possiamo mettere qui non
funziona giustamente perché dobbiamo
mettere qualcosa qui quando
l'elettricità forse che cosa ha fatto
strano tipo in forno c'è un ingranaggio
forse il pezzo che ci mancava però dice
che è un mod quindi è un vino molto slot
quindi va messo qui ok
e poi forse lo possiamo fare il fuoco e
va al modellarlo boer proviamo fuoco
minaccia pensi solo che non ci piace
prova perfetta forse riusciamo a
riattivare il tutto quindi una doppia
mascara qui se ho capito bene giusto
credo
ok niente possiamo attivare questo
ok siamo riusciti ad aprire la porta e
adesso andiamo qui cosa ci aspetterà via
dove stiamo andando adesso che faccio ha
chiuso la porta
non ce l'ha non ci vede esponiamoci
un uomo
lo scopo sarebbe possibile vedere
non ci credo siamo riusciti a
nascondersi nuovamente da mobile un flex
agli uomini avrebbe trovato sul blog
guarda qui c'è una leva però è proprio
di attivarla
versità ho già preso
esce subito
torno a brevi
dove vado adesso
non lo so dovreste piuttosto equa
ce l'ho mai vista
guarda su
vai
adesso
no ok ragazzi nel frattempo si è fatto
buio ma ora provo io le va via con
rigore
[Musica]
proprio dove dove porta porta la sporta
abbiamo provato 10.000 voi prende sempre
aiuto
ora dobbiamo attenderci dobbiamo per
farsi
vedere tu hai dato
lo ricorderemo di voi ha detto dove devo
andare
qui
ci sono anche belle dovevate adesso c'è
qualcosa che girone un ingranaggio la
porta d'uscita da questa quindi ora che
molti anni di carriera la forza uscita
mai
si è fermato tutto
c'è marmi non black sea
mano blu che
questa sarà la via di salvezza spero
e buttarvi che possano vivere più tardi
non lo so
si sta alzando con qualche difficoltà ok
fontana
no questa dove uscita ok ragazzi
risolviamo e questa volta provo a
nascondermi
una volta che apro la porta lei mi
raggiunge quindi proposte non correre
anzi
nessuno che la porta si sta aprendo
la
piccola fai queste fa poca
cosa
si torna quindi ci siamo liberati per
sempre i mobili o blacks mai avuto
secondo me non lo so potrebbe essere che
sia tornata dentro alla fabbrica o è che
si sia ancora non lo so ma che anche
poppy definita molto la botte infatti si
primo liberare hip hop voleva aiutarci e
noi abbiamo detto che avremmo aiutato
lei quindi prima di riuscire a scappare
dobbiamo liberarla c'è una cassetta
guarda che finalmente scopriremo i
segreti
forse finali aspettiamo il play time
dove la tv
il prototipo c'è un esperimento è
scappato e questa sorta di malo ragno
ono rumi dire che dobbiamo affrontare
anche brocchi ha disabilitato le camere
di sicurezza agli allarmi ok in pratica
ha detto che questo strano esperimento
insomma è uscito molto male e abbiamo
detto che l'esperimento che è uscito
meglio agli one chi perché si comporta
bene forse ancora non si erano resi
conto che anche
noi siamo ritornati alla fabbrica vorrà
portare lasciato nemmeno in stage come
facciamo scendere giù araba lì c'è un
giocattolo peso di f1 ragnatele ok
finalmente possiamo scappare da questo
fabbrica voi non sapete ma noi in realtà
stiamo giocando a questa terza parte
poche playtime dalle mille mille ora un
sacco di ore
ecco la posta
posso aiutarti ei 12 4 a 3
il codice del treno o prima benedisse
salì sul treno dobbiamo scappare ok non
era molto felice però attice forte di
strano allora
sì ma devo prendere qualche leva qui c'è
qualcosa scritto vedi ci sono tutte le
cose che dicono non funziona bisogna
ripararlo ok ok presto cerchiamo la
notte con labirinto per arrivare a me
non mi dire che qualsiasi tipo anche un
milione
batta buono si esce ma dove siamo finiti
il cagnolino malefico e fioriere ancora
non l'avevamo visto poi salita qui sul
treno non ci credo che abbiamo finito il
gioco non c'era allora mano vette
non ragazzi non potete capire da quante
ore più bello ramis
allora il codice del treno coniglio con
le orecchie lunghe kissi missy il gatto
e mobile home l'ex ok quindi bozzo si
chisti missy gattino e mammino blacks ok
però dobbiamo cambiare il colore se non
sbaglio ma rovini giallorossoblu ok ho
dato che si cambia da qua si giallo
rosso blu blu
ok è
grande ma funzionava mandato il treno è
ora attivo la leva dai brand di tre
nocciolo valido al prezzo di aborto non
permetterti ancora kiwan dei mesi stiamo
sorteggio ci stiamo muovendo si guarda
dove pochi poiché salvare i puffi a sarà
già sul treno ha detto che ci aspettava
allo stremo
vedo però
si dove sei
sono i clacson tutto forse non andare a
passeggeri
non ci credo che stiamo scappando dalla
fabbrica col traiano domandando
terminato unito all'uso di se non avete
idea di quante ore sappiamo bene
abbiamo stiamo testando velocità
voglio vedere cosa succede alla fine
aspettarci un semaforo però è verde ok
cosa quindi mi devo fermare nel caso di
semafori rospi
e perché
mi sono fatto così
e
non posso lasciarti andare dice
polverini
[Musica]
non ho mai incontrato nessuno come te
per quanto tempo sia stata bloccata
rientrate fa
[Musica]
ho avuto tanto tempo per pensare
casa brescia può essere stata liberata
so che qualsiasi cosa si chiedono di
fare tu sei capace di farla che si sta
rompendo se c'era un allarme poppi non
mi dire o pista fermando il treno ora
che siamo riusciti a scappare finalmente
una discesa o no sembra una montagna
russa non ci credo ma era salvato non
liberata lo fa con il freno possiamo
frenare trentino 3 ma frena
no conoscendo nomi non mi dire che ora
si straceriano fondo rosso ha proibito a
fochetti ci sono salvi
no non lo so non ci credo fossimo torno
alla fine non potevo anche vita stop
train
no
intanto oggi non ci credo che sei
tradito
tutto
ma credo che mi un tavolo tra le parti a
dare prova
bravo
bellissimo sorriso
sembra che si stia frenando sembra che
si sia scusata
no aspetta siamo ancora vivi
eravamo ancora
adesso
che si presero famoso arrivati alla fine
pupi ha imbrogliato per tutto questo
tempo
alla fabbrica abbiamo fatto tutte quelle
prove difficilissime non è giusto e poi
c'è traditora era con imposto sin
dall'inizio che ci fidavamo di le pesava
guerra che l'abbiamo salvata da un
bambino blend detto che siccome voleva
compagnia voleva stare con noi ha
bloccato il treno c'è ci ha fatto
distruggere il treno è sicuramente nel
prossimo episodio saremo ancora pure a
scappare da poppi chissà da chi altro
fateci sapere nei commenti qual è stato
il vostro momento preferito per noi
diciamo le proposte la prova quella di
bonzo quel nero abbelliscono i pulsanti
questa è questa corsa entrano è stata
bellissima
l'ha fatto ora vi lasciamo 4 catherine
hsu duplicare prevedere i nostri altri
video nel caso quella che preferite è
realizzare ciò